[Music]
hello everyone and welcome again to the
friendship onion
welcome everyone to the friendship onion
and billy may i be the first to welcome
you to the french onion welcoming people
to the french onion and i would like to
welcome you who have also welcomed the
people and me to the friendship onion
you're welcome welcome welcome everyone
it's great to see you tom it's been a
little while hasn't it we often see each
other over weekends i haven't seen you
or possibly of a mid-week and this week
we've both been kind of busy running
around it's been this week has flown in
as they say
around like our ass is on fire hasn't it
been i've been like a blue ass fly and
it's been roasting hot in l.a and i've
been desperately trying to keep my
garden alive by watering it but because
it's so hot i can't really garden
between the hours of eleven and five so
i have to do it before or after but my
garden is really struggling just leave
it no no but is that not what would
happen in nature yes but i have a lot of
plants that don't necessarily naturally
fit in you have a lot of lovely drought
tolerant cactus and succulents and
hearty things like rosemaries and irises
i have some delicate things that need
water so you try and keep them alive now
and then as you move into the autumnal
winter months it gets cold the roots
grow and they get strong and hardy so
that's one thing so give them yeah do
what you can do a little bit of water
anything to report this week everything
being tickety-boo everything seems
pretty good
uh wait you see my knee guy
yeah what did you
say still a bit wobbly so we're working
on strength
and
um flexibility strength of the knee and
also
trying to get the arse bigger yeah
because the strength of the knee comes
from all over you could have a weak
ankle that could affect your knee wow
and when you say because you've said it
a while now that you need to get your
ass bigger it's the cheeks not
necessarily the hole or will the hole
get bigger with the cheeks or do you
want the hole to stay the same size as
it is now oh the the hole will not in
any way influence your knee so you're
not working out the hole
the cheeks
and you're trying to get the cheeks
would you say
twice as big as they are now
the size doesn't matter i'm not going
again for any sort of a competition
right uh it's mainly for stability and
strength in the knee okay so dense
muscle is what i need well i wish you
luck with that thank you
you and i have been watching some quite
fantastic television this week oh it's
been good yeah two things really stood
out to me do you remember our fantastic
astronaut guest that we had a while back
and he said to us you must watch this
documentary about the apollo missions on
netflix i remember that i watched that
the night before last well it's
fantastic
can you remember the name of it i think
it's called epo apollo something i'll
send you thank you
i'd like to watch that great it's very
emotional
oh it was called apollo 6 john said
apollo 11. john said he that but then he
did that yeah uh it's called apollo 11.
it's great it's quite emotional at the
end uh fraught with danger and you have
a massive amount of respect for the
people in the control room oh yeah as
well as the astronauts that's what it
deals with more than anything else is
the people in the control rooms i look
forward to that mission control
well they've got a big job oh my god did
they ever what else were you watching
well another thing that has just been
amazing this week and i i
reluctantly uh binged it i didn't mean
to but i just couldn't stop watching it
is this documentary on hulu called
mccartney321 which is
brilliant rick rubin and paul mccartney
sat down just talking through his music
you watched it as well right i just
watched the first episode how many is
there six i think right cool yeah i
watched another one today
i really liked it i loved it and there's
so much that i loved about it but one of
my favorite things it sounds a little
ego maniacal in terms of mccartney but i
don't think it was
he takes so much joy in music now of
course he's listening to his own music
but a lot of times he might be listening
to
a piccolo trumpet in penny lane or you
know a a
tuba player on sergeant pepper so he's
not he's not getting super excited about
his voice or his music but every every
so often he will get stoked on his bass
playing but he just is so excited and
stoked on music you know
eyes i love how his mind thinks he's
always thinking
in harmony and counter melodies he's
never really sort of going oh yeah that
melody ba ba ba he's he's always like
bad at night he's always on a different
like when they were talking about um
well my guitar gently weeps and they
pulled down everything and left the base
up
and rick rubin was saying
that just sounds like a totally
different song
and and then
paul mccartney started singing a totally
different melody oh yeah this could be
it could be this could be this
and yeah and i love that the the band
was so kind of close by that time that
paul mccartney could play a bass line
like that that totally sounds like a
different song yeah and how his
musical mind thought of doing that is is
brilliant because you might have done
that with a counter melody on a voice
but to do it with the bass yeah
he's such a unique talent mccartney i
mean obviously he plays the bass the
guitar left-handed i wonder what that
does to uh people because you know he's
playing it in a way that is slightly
unnatural to him yeah
but then the other thing is he started
learning acoustic guitar and then
obviously electric guitar and no one
wanted to play bass george harrison is
the best guitarist in the beatles so he
said there's no way i'm playing bass and
lennon was like well no i'm i'm the
front man i'm going to play rhythm to go
along with the band the drive of the
band so mccartney is like okay i'll play
bass but instead of just saying
instead of approaching it as i'll be the
bass player keeping that kind of bass
line he he almost plays lead bass
doesn't really yeah it's it's brilliant
and and rick reuben said that he is
relatively coy about his bass guitar uh
playing and the influence that it's had
over the years but it ha it must have
told bass guitarist you don't have to
sit in the background just following
along with the bass drum you can lead
forward people like you know the jam has
a very strong lead base doesn't it or
the police has a very strong lead base
i'm sure that must be influenced by
mccarthy yeah absolutely
it's funny man my wonderful dad
is quite snooty about mccartney
you know like um i liked his early stuff
in the beatles but then when he got a
bit wacky i'm not i'm not kind of into
him like well i said this to my dad last
time i'm like
this is the guy that wrote yesterday
this is the guy that wrote blackbird
this is the guy that wrote here there
and everywhere you know i wonder if
maybe with my dad it's because he's a
peer you know they're the same ish age
so it's hard to kind of
kind of
you know see his brilliance whatever and
my dad said well you know he's kind of
he's not he's not as influenced as
influential as he used to be but it's
difficult to sustain that beatles level
of influence and also i think
i could be wrong here but i think your
dad likes sort of off center artist
doesn't he yeah he likes leonard cohen
yeah so people who are
cool whereas i think
mccartney
did music in a different way you know he
definitely touched on deep stuff you
know but i think he was much more
interested as we've said about melody
and harmony and changes in tempo like
all the wing stuff where it just sounds
like there's four songs stuck together
all that stuff is much more mccartney
and and takes as much if not more skill
than you know some of some of the stuff
that um
people would think of as more off center
i think some people get a thing against
mccartney because they think he's too
middle of the road yeah and and i think
that's because it's you know he's in
silly little love songs yeah yeah you
know he's rapes about that but actually
the melody and the harmony and and
that's why he went on to orchestrate and
stuff you know he's got that mind he won
an either novello award for that i mean
he won he
he very much wants to write catchy songs
that hook into your head
that was a driving force it seems for
paul mccartney whereas i think
if you look at lenin and like you know
something like revolution nine as an
example
he just thought well i want to make art
and i wanted i wanted to smash you over
the head there's a great rolling stone
interview with lennon where he's
interviewed by jan wenner who was the
editor of rolling stone and the creator
of the rolling stone magazine and
lennon's talking about marcel duchamp
the artist and he said i love him i love
the fact that he took a bicycle and he
put it in the corner of the room and he
said that's art you deal with that yeah
you know and i think that was one of the
things with lenin ways like i'm going to
i'm going to challenge what you think is
our yeah by saying i'm an artist take
this and people like oh i don't like
that he's like well i don't care i'm not
and i think mccartney is almost the
antithesis yeah right he's like i'm
going to give you melodies i'm going to
give you different tones i'm going to
give you orchestra i'm going to learn
how to play this instrument really well
and i'm going to play it the best i can
and look how beautiful that is yeah
it's amazing that they met together and
created that amazing thing it's a
brilliant documentary if you guys are
interested in paul mccartney if you're
interested in how music is made if
you're interested in the beatles
check out mccartney321 on hulu it's
fantastic
and also rick rubin seems like a lovely
guy
and
the beard the hair the shorts he looks
so comfortable brilliant he features
quite heavily in the beastie boys
documentary and he had a lot to do with
them turning a corner from
naughty little daring rappers into
actually a band doing something
significant yeah rick rubin's a very
smart guy good well should we bring
rosie in i think we should because he's
an amazing man let's have a lovely chat
with our wonderful friend
michael rosenbaum
guys should we start with the song since
there's three people here two of which
are in ben's you just gave me a freight
there really you scared me i was looking
the other way hang on do that thing that
conductors do i don't have a pen i'll do
it what have you got i'll do it with my
uh cocky right
you know how conductors do that yeah but
we should be choosing
cocky car key i heard you i'll do it
with my cocky
that's what i heard please don't do it
with that my car key you know
give a visit give us it
[Music]
ready
boom
all i wanted was the love you gave
wow guys that was fun that could not
have been nicer what a lovely
introduction to lovely michael rosenbaum
hey y'all hi rosie how's it going i'm
really excited to be here i'm excited to
be on your podcaster once we're excited
to have you
and rosie's here because he's he's
basically the spin doctor of all of this
in he builds he is the guy that started
the friendship onion yeah by accident
yeah
in your home
kind of i mean are you talking about
because you guys i guess you did the
pilot yeah the first episode at my house
in my studio yeah and you weren't sure
what the hell you wanted to do or what
you were doing but you said let's do it
he said
michael at you you don't said michael
will probably let us use his equipment
for free and i said if it's for free i
mean
well there it was i described you as a
mensch a mensch which is a fantastic
word in yiddish that means a generous
man
good man good morning you are very
menchie well i i i uh i try to be
i don't think i always am okay but my
intentions are usually that i think
you've always been
moderately matchy thank you i i
appreciate it you're a medium i'm hard
on myself though wow are you not hard on
yourself i don't think i'm not hard on
myself no if anything you could be
harder on yourself
but you make this a good observation
i enjoy your podcast a lot yeah thank
you man inside of you inside of you with
michael rosenbaum yeah i really enjoy it
i was just listening to one coming up
and i like you listen to one that's
coming up no i listened to one as i was
driving
i was listening to one with seth green
actually and had a lot of really great
things in it because i think you you let
people relax
and then you get inside of them
yeah you know people always ask me it's
funny
people come up to me or they'll email me
and say hey you know i really love your
podcast and this and i honestly think
i'm surprised
because it could go either way i never
listen to them i just interview and i'm
like okay i'm just i i'm sort of like
just a regular person asking questions
like so i feel sort of like an idiot
remember that chris farley show on
senate live where he's like uh paul
mccartney you were
you're uh a beatle idiot stupid what are
you doing so i i don't it's not like
that but in a sense i'm just going and
going do you ever get scared when you're
auditioning do you ever get uh and i
just start going down a rabbit hole of
of questions and
people think it's just really
conversational and fun and i i love
doing it it is and i have a dd so but
when i put these cans on they call them
cans you know yeah yeah that's technical
talk i learned it lovely but when i i i
start to focus yeah cause i could hear
your voice and i and i so it's it's nice
this podcast is sponsored by betterhelp
is there something interfering with your
happiness or maybe
preventing you from achieving your goals
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help
it is a professional counselling done
securely online
there is a broad range of expertise
available which may not be locally
available in many areas
and this service is available for
clients worldwide
you can log into your account anytime
and send a message to your counselor
visit betterhelp.com
onion that's better
h-e-l-p
and join the over one million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional
in fact
so many people have been using better
help that they are recruiting additional
counsellors in all 50 states
special offer for the friendship onion
listeners
get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
committing to a fitness routine can be
hard trying to find the time getting to
the gym all that stuff not easy
peloton makes it much easier
and now
with 400
off their original bike there's never
been a better time to start your fitness
revolution
i use a peloton bike and i love it i
think it's fantastic i'm not one for
making plans and uh
routines so i just find some time in the
day
15 minutes half an hour 45 minutes when
i'll jump on the bike and get a great
workout lots of classes to choose from
lots of styles of music styles of
instructor you can find the perfect
thing just for you and i've started
using it for the strength training as
well which is fantastic you can get
outside lift some weights it feels good
experience motivation like never before
with the peloton bike
now four hundred dollars less
go to one peritone dot com to learn more
that's o n e p e l o t o n
dot com
i wonder if that's what it is rosie that
maybe in that hour and a half two hours
where you are sat with the mic and the
cans on you do become focused because i
think you are a very focused interviewer
in the couple of times that you and i
have sat down and then i sat down with
bills as well that was a good one i
remember saying to you
it's going to be a kind of role in chat
but he is going to get into it which is
the whole thing about inside you right
right i don't just i don't just get into
it like i think if you just are there to
ask questions and you have a list of
questions it comes off
kind of cold and everyone can do anybody
can do that anyone could have a list of
questions and ask you
but for me i just kind of go oh you know
i just uh you know outside when when you
were coming in the house you said this
thing and it made me laugh and then we
just start talking yeah
and then you know rayne wilson from the
office yeah um every time i
name drop you have to drop something so
rayne wilson
uh was at the house
no if he dropped his wallet because it
would crack the floorboards just massive
leg
rain wilson came over and i go hey how
you doing man thanks for coming over he
goes yeah my dog just died i'm like oh
[ __ ] can you say [ __ ] yeah you can say
[ __ ] and balls on this show oh i heard
you don't swear very often though i
don't actually i don't i keep it alex i
keep it all in like a cancer eating my
stomach
but anyway rain came in and said his dog
died so the first thing i said was like
you just came in here and you said your
dog died why are you here yeah cause
you're not just opened up and he got a
little emotional and uh i think when
people hear about my dysfunction and i
open up about who i am and what i've
been you know they tend to open up yeah
yeah so i think that's part of it so
when you say dysfunction list you said
you had adhd which is attention
deficit just i think attention deficits
or i think a lot of people will say they
have it but i mean anybody who knows me
knows that if i'm in a conversation or
something usually and i just hear a song
like oh i love this song who sings this
like dude i'm freaking talking to you
isn't that everyone or is or do we just
both have a dd like if i'm talking to if
i'm talking to you
and then your wife comes in and says
something i can easily be distracted by
billy's wife is that is that addi
slightly distracted just now bye michael
says when he puts on the cans he focuses
yeah he's not put the cans on you've
only got one side of the can on i've
adopted this i feel like i'm the only
person that's focused at the minute
oh wait a minute now i'm focused is that
better i think so turn it up a little
bit how's that is that you is that is
that better
no that's good for me i'm i'm good oh
i'm good okay you're good i'm i think
i'm good they look massive on you
because you're a tiny little head i'm
normally in charge of that thing yeah
and now michael's taking over
the volumes by the way i i noticed you
have good facial hair and i shaved my
beard and i tried to have a little
mustache and go and it's kind of
embarrassing you're laughing at it i
think you look good no it's kind of
embarrassing i don't know i just tried
it a few days though it's not quite
grown in yet right it'll grow thicker
than that i don't know really i never
really do i mean maybe a little thicker
my brother matthew hello matthew if
you're watching
fantastic facial like he can do like
spanish conquistador kind of mustaches i
wish i could kind of come around like
this and sometimes my brother will do
really weird things where he'll shave
all of his face
apart from this bit
and this bit and then he'll just let it
grow to see what happens it's weird and
you think that's not going to work it
does it works yeah that's not for me
what about you i've never imagined you
with facial hair
i have i grew a fantastic beard a few
years ago i can attest like a
full-on beard that just took over like a
fisherman it was like a crater jackson
beard like yeah like a young gandalf
like a full-on
you know and she's a beard and it looked
good it's like stuff great yeah and i
feel like
i feel like people really took me more
seriously
oh there's billy boyd
it's not only better to get serious not
only that bills but that but that was at
a time where you grew the beard
for a shakespearean role so when
someone's coming over to you saying i
like your beard and you go well it's
from uh shakespearean role then people
have to take i'm playing banquet i'm
playing banquet you were banquo and
macbeth yeah that's a good role yeah it
was good i was a good ghost
i was
don't tell me don't tell me i can't
remember malcolm
no i'd uh no
duff nose would have been great if it
was malcolm
ross you would be a wonderful ross my
sir tis call the evil the most
miraculous work of this good king
i don't remember at all oh i love that
though it was very good wasn't it right
was it really yeah i was thinking about
this earlier it's like when you guys
talk i mean
people are just i think they tend to
listen more because you just sound smart
and you've got that accent but i wish i
had an accent in britain in britain
would just sound like everyone else yeah
is that true yeah i guess that is true
but here you sound smarter you could say
the stupidest thing and still come off
smart right right that's good to know
yeah it's true don't you guys agree out
there i mean when they speak it sounds
smarter than if i for instance um
i'll say something okay oh my god last
night i had the worst diarrhea
now that's how i say it now you say it
and see if it sweetens it a little
oh my god last night i had the worst
diarrhea
sexier sexier for sure yeah
oh last night i had the worst diarrhea
it's just it's more acceptable people
like oh i'm sorry to hear that from me
they're like oh you're a pig
does anyone actually remember the last
time they had diarrhea no uh no it's
been a while knock on wood
i was bloated about a week ago oh what
did you do
eating a bunch of bread well for my
birthday i had uh
beppo and i ate far too much and really
stuffed myself and i've never done this
before i was so full
that i actually had to make myself throw
up oh wow and i've never done that and i
go because my friend goes listen make
yourself throw up and i go uh why are
you telling me to do that do you do that
i hope you don't do that you know but if
you're really that full and it hurts
just get rid of it because i felt like
it was up there did you not feel like
instead of that the first thing you
could do is maybe just go and try for a
for a shot
i i was too bloated i didn't think i had
to poop i think it was at first it was
uh i hate that feeling when it's stuck
like up here yeah that's what happens i
was really bloated
you had that yes also if anyone out
there can help me with this problem
doesn't happen as much anymore but i
went through a period of
i've told you this before
pooping food
actual food like a piece of broccoli
yeah full
blueberries
maybe uh you know a piece of a carrot
mainly fruit and vegetables other stuff
would like break down weird but i was
astounded i would turn around and be
like that is my dinner there's that bit
of my dinner and here's the thing it's
specifically for dom that would be
disturbing because i don't know if you
know this about dom
he can he he can be quite good at
spending money but then for small things
frugal very frugal yeah very tight with
it yeah so see if he'd spent money on
say organic
a punnet of organic blueberries
and he pooped them out it's a waste i
could see him digging through that and
eating it again yeah yeah i mean if i
was in this
situation for sure
because he would not like the idea that
he'd spent four dollars on a punnett
organic blueberries only put straight
through with no vitamins i am i'm i get
it from my dad i'm all about bargains we
were on a flight back from new york last
week
and i'm chatting to billy about two
hours into the flight and i come over
and go
you on the internet you went yeah i got
wi-fi i went free you went no i well no
i'm not getting that he was like you're
not paying for the flight you've not
paid for the hotel we're getting all
this cash to do this appearance and
you're not going to pay like what was it
10 bucks on the flight yeah
i was like no no no no it's not free why
is that i'm weirdly because in my mind
growing up growing up i bet it had
something to do with it yeah my dad is
well both my parents are good with money
they're not cheap in any way but they're
both you know they're careful and i
think both my parents gave my brother
and i less pocket money than we actually
needed so if we needed seven pounds 50
they'd give us a fiver and be like well
you work it out wash my car for two quid
and then you'll get seven pounds instead
so they always made us kind of work that
extra bit and in my mind on the flight
not only do i do i enjoy being away from
wi-fi for a few hours and being like i
have to watch a movie i have to play
nintendo switch whatever but the other
thing is well i could wait
and in four or five hours then i'll have
the tree of emails and you know messages
that's true i understand that yeah i i
can understand that part but i i'm
definitely one because my my dad was
always very frugal and you know uh uh so
were my grandparents everybody was
always it was always about this and i i
to me i just wanted to be the opposite i
wanted to be a big tipper i wanted to
uh if i want something and i could
afford it i'm getting it i don't think
twice about it um i you know uh i'm
smart with my money but i'm also
i'll just i'll spend i'll spend my money
billy taught me a very one of my the
most important life lessons probably the
most important life lesson that i've got
from you so far wow yeah
um
just yell at never eat yellow snow no it
was we were in new zealand you know this
story we're in new zealand very early
days shooting maybe even rehearsing
walking around in the daytime it's lunch
time
and we walk past mcdonald's and i say
well so we just jump in here we'll just
get a quick burger and we can carry on
with our day and billy's like no no it's
lunch now i'm gonna go take myself to
lunch and have that hour-long experience
of lunch i'm not gonna waste it on a
five-minute crappy little burger and at
the time it didn't really resonate but
over the next couple of years i thought
actually three opportunities a day to
really enjoy and make a decision of self
love as opposed to self abuse or you
know just
and that came from you
you know
you do eat relatively well don't you
i've never seen you eat at mcdonald's no
i i can't think of the last time i'd
eaten a mcdonald's what's the naughtiest
food i mean you and i eat pizza here and
there oh i'll eat pizza but it's good
elite and
like haribo gums
i love those gums i don't know what
hairy ball gums are harry po you know
like berry balls
you know those gums and
and they're chewy and you get you can
get them fizzy sometimes yeah
by the way you just said you guys were
just talking about that you kind of flew
over it pretty fast
but no when you say you take that hour
i'm going to have lunch
that automatically gave me a feeling
inside that i kind of rushed through
things i kind of just i'm like oh i have
to eat now so let's just eat fast and
get it over with i have to do this let's
get that over with and
that's something i really have to work
on i have to learn how to
i don't know for lack of a better word
like relish the moment i have to learn
how to just be in the moment and be like
hey you have a meal here you don't have
to scarf it down you have the time to
relax
it's probably healthier
but i don't do that i think i i think i
rush through life i'm gonna be honest
with you i think i need to i know i need
to work on it i need to work on just
being more present more
relaxed breathe a little bit yeah you
know well mastication is extremely
important i don't know what that was
chewing especially as you get older and
older but in terms of so billy's naughty
thing is like haribo mine is probably
haribo as well what's your naughty
little oh i feel ashamed of myself treat
when you're in the house and you're on
your dog looks like he will eat so much
that he'll have to make himself sick
i only did that once that night after uh
buca which i loved thank you for the
meal buca but is there something where
you're like i know i shouldn't be eating
this but i love it
yeah
i have frozen white castle burgers in
the freezer never had them never heard
of white castle i've heard the white
castle because that's a square
there's a square tiny burger and there's
establishments like white castle and
crystal and they're not healthy but i
remember as a kid i think it's the
nostalgia of it all my dad would order
like 35 of them and we would scarf down
these little burgers left you know and
so i saw them at the grocery store and i
keep them in my freezer every once in a
while i'll just put them in the
microwave for about 45 seconds and my
burger's ready and i'll pop one down
when i was a kid i used to love cereal
eating cereal as a kid what could be
nicer but now when you've grown up you
realise i can't eat that
too much sugar too much junk so what do
we do
i'll tell you what we do
magic spoon cereal
magic spoon
has zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams
of protein and only four net grams of
carbs in each serving and only 140
calories
and it's got fantastic flavors cocoa
fruity frosting my favorite peanut
butter blueberry cinnamon cookies and
cream maple waffle
subscribe today to flavor you love
and you can get cereal shipped to your
doorstep
not to mention saving more than 25
on every order
you can choose four flavors you love
edit your subscription to switch it up
and keep yourself stocked up on cereal
go to magicspoon.com
slash
onion5 or use the promo code onion5 at
checkout to get five dollars off your
order and try it today remember if you
subscribe to magic spoon you'll get five
dollars off on top of the 25 savings
for subscribing
subscribe and get your delicious
guilt-free cereal on the regular at
magicspoon.com
onion5 and use the code onion5 to save
big thank you magic spoon for sponsoring
this episode
there's much more to nutrition than just
calories
your diet plays a huge role in your
microbiome which in turn impacts your
mental and physical well-being
but now they're learning about the
connection between your gut microbiome
health
and type 2 diabetes
pendulum glucose control is the first
and only medical probiotic that's
designed to manage a1c
and blood glucose levels through the
health
of your microbiome
with pendulum
you can feel in control of your levels
not the other way around
it's formulated and bottled in the us
with the highest safety and quality
standards
non-gmo project verified
take control of your glucose levels
today
try pendulum glucose control for 90 days
if you're not satisfied with your levels
you get your money back
visit
pendulumlife.com to find out more
and use promo code onion for 20 off your
first bottle of membership
that's
p e n
d
u l u m
l i f
e
dot com
promo code
onion
so the thing about white castle that
defines them from other people is mini
sliders
i mean mini they're like this big
they're really small and they're i mean
they're just tiny slab of meat
really soft bread have you had one never
i don't think you have it yeah i don't
know if you should but uh you kind of
made me feel like i would like to i'm
kind of in the mood for a burger now
well we're not going to have that just
now no time to have one after
no time well should we do should we do a
little oh god oh god oh that's the
angriest i've seen you in about 14 days
we are here to hear about michael and
he's talking about his dad and all that
there and i want to know oh you're
trying to get inside of it oh no where
did you grow up
what part of these united states of
america did you grow up i was born in
new york in oceanside new york oceanside
long island
nasa community hospital and uh we moved
when i was a kid my dad was like
delivered newspapers worked in a lab
uh
we moved to connecticut but i really
grew up in indiana from the time i was
eight so
southern indiana right borderline of
kentucky and that's where i grew up in a
small town in indiana if that was
america if my hand was america where is
indiana um it's just uh west of your
ring
this way right there that's about where
it is okay thank you so you're down a
bit so thin
yep southern indiana so kind of
mid-westy southern indiana borderline
kentucky is it's a bit southern i mean i
had friends who had some accidents hey
rose what are you getting in tonight man
yeah and they were just a little bit
like that and some people just you know
if they're from kentucky they you know
they have a real accent people were very
very laid back you fly in indiana and
you the second you land you get off that
plane and you are immediately just
relaxed there's something just
i don't know what it is is it because is
it very hot down there hotness it's just
like it just i i don't know i think
people aren't in a rush to get
everywhere well that's lovely at some
point yeah but that but that's what you
want to work on yeah that's what i want
to see you grew up with that so then how
did you get involved in performance and
being an actor i didn't know what i was
gonna do and i was kind of a lost soul
but i remember like uh i used to hang
out with my friends and their families
and spend the night at friends houses a
lot my parents didn't really care what i
was doing they they sort of were like oh
you want to spend the night at david
idleman's danny cutters nate shepherds i
would just spend the night they danny uh
uh david died david passed away sorry to
bring that up
but um so i was always i was kind of a
lost soul i didn't know what i was who i
was and but i i noticed i made people
laugh like my friends parents they
always thought i was funny okay
so finally my senior year in high school
i did a play
and i was nervous as [ __ ] i was like i
don't know if i can do this i don't even
know if i can get in front of an
audience but i remember the next day uh
i'm walking down the hallway in this
popular kid chris pro his name was pro
p-i-e-r-r-o-t
and he came up to me goes
you're really funny in that play
and he walked away
and i thought
holy [ __ ]
that's it
i've gotta do this because
the popular guy just said i'm i'm funny
i was good in that right and so i think
growing up i was doing it for all the
wrong reasons what was the play it was
greece
and i was vince fontaine the wacky dj oh
yeah yeah the guy who comes to the
dancing yeah right but i remember
doing it because it's approval it's
instant gratification it's
acceptance and so when i was on stage
people like oh and you're really good
and i needed that
and so i don't even know if there was a
so if there was
it's taken all these years later to find
out like do you really love doing it i
think there's some love to it but i
think i did it because it was the only
thing i could do at least they felt at
the time yeah yeah so uh that's how i
kind of got into it i prefer doing
podcasts to acting now
no i really i i still
still want to act i think i just want to
i'm very fortunate and grateful but i
you know i can do the things that i want
to do so i'm not going to just do a show
to do a show right if i don't think you
know i don't want to be on set on
something i don't like just because of
because for the money
and you know if it's content that i go
wow this would be fun this would be a
great time because there has to be a
certain amount of joy
on set you have to go to work i mean
look you're very fortunate if you get to
go to work and have a good time most
people hate their jobs
so if you have the choice to actually go
to work and enjoy it and you know enjoy
what you do
and some people whatever they're doing
they can be on the world's shittiest
television show and they don't care
because they're acting and that's great
but for me i want to go be able to go
you know what i really like this role i
like the people i'm working with i want
to i think i could really have fun and
do great work that's the goal
so
i love doing the podcast i love writing
i love i'm trying to sell stuff but you
know um
look if i needed to work if i needed if
i was broke right now i go dom you're
going to do a movie in about a month did
they need any roles yeah uh
because i would beg you for one yeah i
would do anything i would work i'd work
it uh yeah part of i always feel like
did you hear that i sounded like it was
like a whispering wind no it's good it
was good i always feel like part of my
salary when i say yes when i when my
agent eventually says we're now at the
point where we have to say yes or no if
i say yes i feel like part of that yes
part of that payment is
regardless from now onwards when you
walk on set you have to act like you're
having a good time act in the role but
also act like i'll do all the shitty
whatever
no i mean the the angsty stuff if i have
it i'll do that when i'm away from set
but walking on set
with with technicians and people that
probably don't want to be there at all
and getting paid 15 times less than me
right part of my salary maybe it's a
guilt complex is like hey how's it going
hey how's it going hey how's it going
how's it going because i just think
you're getting paid you you have to i
always set that example i agree with you
100 i think when you go on set you have
to
what's the word you have to uh
to the crew you have to set a
tone a tone that's nice that's well done
i don't know if that was going to come
out yeah but you do i think it's an
obligation we have to you know i always
want the crew to have fun i want to have
fun if they're having fun
if i'm having fun they're having fun
yeah that could make for a really good
product but there's there's some actors
who are really kind of dark and keep to
themselves and don't want to talk to
anybody and that's fine but i've always
been the guy that wants to know what the
director of photography's name is and i
want to know what the grip's name is and
the the gaffer and i want to know what
everybody's name is i wanna
it just makes me i feel like it's
a team effort and they're gonna probably
work harder for you and make you look
good yeah because you're just they like
you and also don't you sometimes think
that like i understand if someone has a
very heavy day of lines and it's an
angsty scene or they're in a scene where
their best friend's gonna die or they're
gonna die or it's sad or whatever i
understand maybe you're in your head and
that's your process but
you know i do
i do reject this notion of whatever
someone comes to work and they have a
line in a scene that's nothing it's
throwaway but for some reason
because whatever they're they're an
actor they have to be all angsty and
this method thing i'm just like that's
that's very often nowadays is an excuse
to be a [ __ ] do you know what i mean
like yeah daniel day-lewis is method and
we see by the proof of his work that
like it seems to really work out for
daniel day-lewis and that is his process
but for someone who's 25th on the call
sheet and they come in
and they're a [ __ ] for no reason
they're like well i'm not a dick at a
method you're like method all you're
doing is saying hi tony and then he's
walking off the camera right can you see
that i never see i sometimes see that
really i've worked with those type of
people i always feel like guest stars
are people that are way down on the call
sheet a lot of times they're it's harder
it's harder it's definitely harder for a
guest star to come in and do those lines
and be great and come into a whole big
family that's been filming and then you
know usually they're nervous yeah
usually they're just trying to get the
lines out or they're trying to you know
uh i always feel for those for those
folks i definitely think it's hard yeah
oh man it's it's it's brutal to come in
and just like all right here he goes oh
yeah he's the guest star yeah let's go
and action here let's go right and
you're like
uh and you could sometimes see people's
lips kind of quivering
yeah people get nervous man have you
ever gotten nervous oh my god i've been
nervous on camera
yeah yeah i think i have i'm trying to
think of specifics now
but like being a guester you're
absolutely right and you especially in a
show that you watch
you know when you come in and there's a
little bit of you that's going i
remember this set all right you know and
oh wait a minute i'm in this now and
i've got like a page of like a speech to
do or something i get yeah i get a
little bit nervous then
but normally it's it's kind of fun it's
yeah i don't know you have the skill set
generally to work it out right i find
that i've only had it happen once and it
was recent on star wars but when you
when you clamp up and everything starts
to get tight
then the lines that you've remembered
fly out your head and everything's tight
and your body's tight so for me i stay
in a sense of play in a state of play
not to be silly and goofy and so that
people think i don't take my job
seriously it's to keep everything
loose and free yeah so i'm always
chatting with craig hey over there all
right that's cool
that's really that's a process i do that
too you know who else did that i don't
know if he still does it but i saw these
behind the scenes of the making of
what's eating gilbert grape with
leonardo dicaprio and they say that he
was like you know he was playing an
intense character a mentally challenged
character and he would just be like oh
and just probably and actually he's like
you know gilbert
and just jump into it mama
you know and like he would jump into
this serious role and then cut and then
just playful and doing all [ __ ] and
making people laugh i don't know if he
still does it but i go oh cool somebody
else does that as a process because he's
drove johnny depp crazy supposedly on
that film because he was like that the
entire time and they've obviously become
friends later and johnny depper said in
in the press he said oh he drove me
crazy because all he did was jump around
being silly but i think that was
dicaprio's process of staying loose and
improvisational in his in his role you
know
i went i flew to uh
london to do this very small role in
star wars and jj said to me you won't
you won't have the script until the
night before but don't don't worry about
it because we're going to change it the
following morning that would make my
nerves round oh this is crazy so he said
the stop we went out for dinner that
night and we're as we're leaving dinner
he said you'll have pages back at your
room but he said try not to worry about
them too much because by the time we get
into work the next day they'll be
different i was like okay fine whatever
and he said it's it's a chunk but don't
worry about it oh so yeah well that's
not cool well whatever that makes me
that's my biggest nightmare yeah i don't
learn lines fast right right it was
definitely it was definitely an issue so
but i said to bills i don't um the irony
now is i'll never forget this line but
on the day [ __ ] if i could remember it
so i had to say
it was cut from the movie because
obviously it did not it did not work
they gave they gave the stuff to daisy
instead but the line was you can't get
to hexagonal you need a super illuminite
lodestone star compass attuned to
hyperspace vectors [ __ ] you jj hey jj i
love your movies [ __ ] you so and that
was the first line
and they just getting they kept how many
times did they have to repeat it
so i have to say that then
then a couple of oh then a couple of
characters talk and then i have this
this chunk it's about a half a page of
dialogue exposition exposition so jj
came over he said
over by where that globe is he said
there's there's a
camera on what have you seen the
panaconda it's like the biggest crane
for uh for a panavision yeah yeah they
call it the panaconda it's it's massive
so we said we're gonna start the camera
on the panaconda
just do some business you know press
some dials and stuff
he said the camera's going to come over
everyone's going to do some business and
as you feel the camera kind of get to
here as it rests and settles
start your line i'm like all right fine
i've done this before no worries
but there's all droids and monsters and
creatures moving over and as it's coming
over i'm thinking
i don't know my first line
so i i try and do it
you um it's not gonna you need a uh what
sorry jay sorry and he goes no it's
noise we'll reset we'll go again but the
reset
the reset is like three minutes because
the camera has to go back the droids the
monsters so now i'm thinking
if i keep asking them to reset
if i do that four times that's 15 20
minutes
wasted and this is star wars and they do
not have time on this set and eventually
jay came over and he was like it's fine
it's fine but you do we do need you to
kind of get it now and i'm like yeah
yeah how many how many takes
we probably before we got it we probably
did
8 10 something like that
[Music]
i'm like
but if i've not got it in three takes
you know what i would have said
jj with all due
you know respect uh i don't learn like
you gave me these lines i i don't learn
lines fast i need to have them soak in
yeah or you know what you know what just
have a have somebody have a thing we'll
do it in one take i'll nail it yeah i
could do that it's
you know that's terrifying jay's like
i've had that close personal friend of
mine i know i know you're playing with
the big boys there and also he's he's
put his trust in me for good or bad
reason he said to the studio i got just
the guy for this now like you do realize
he's gonna come in and do a page of
dialogue day one jet lagged he's like i
gotta go so when he says to you to me
you're the guy i can't then go i am your
guy but could you just put it on a card
and give me a minute so i was like i got
it i got it and i did get it were you
thinking of write it down
no i was just you know what oscar isaac
was really cool with me they were all
really cool but oscar saw what was going
on he could see that i was in my head
and he knew i don't know how he must
have just guessed he knew that i needed
to be in a
state of play so he just started goofing
off for me my character was called
beaumont he's like ah bowman come on you
got this thing come on let's go again
and it brought me out of the tightness
and then i got it and i sat to him
afterwards and i was like thanks for
that he's like hey man say the line
again
you can't get to x goal you need a super
illuminate lodestone star compass
attuned to hyperspace vectors
[ __ ] if i could get it that day how long
for you to learn that
um i think if i sat in my trailer for
four days i no i probably i mean i don't
i don't know i think i could probably
get it like within i mean did you have
the morning to kind of get it i had the
morning i would want to sleep on that
one that's what i'm saying i want to
sleep on it
and no sleep no know what inside out you
dream about almost when you say the
lines before you go to bed you go to bed
you go i know these i know these and you
wake up it's nice yeah it's a great
feeling but i didn't know it's not a
good i i once had
um hey
we we're going to shoot a scene from the
next episode um it's a small though uh
today
yes yeah
and i i i had that on another thing they
gave me this scene the day of they go
we're shooting it after lunch and it's
just chunks of dialogue for three pages
and i go
my whole day is ruined right i'm just
trying to learn this
you've ruined my day what season are you
in here i don't even know it's probably
it's probably season two or three it was
early on but still and then i had i
remember wes craven i had this
i worked for west craven i had this
monologue
and he just goes
i'm telling you i think we did 14 takes
14 takes and it was just because he
wanted a certain way and i don't know i
i was doing it trying to do it his way
without even understanding why
i just was like and i loved him i love i
just wanted to make him happy
and he was really cool about it and we
finally got it and on the last day he
goes now do it like christopher walken
wow because he knows like you know i do
impressions and stuff so
it was it turned out okay but there have
been some times on set where i'm like i
don't want to act anymore please get me
on a first plane to egypt or somewhere
out of the [ __ ] of this country i do not
i can't do this i'm not capable and then
there's been some times when i'm like
you're genius yeah you're [ __ ] so
good and then so bad it's it's just
that's been my only day ever on set and
jay said a really amazing thing where i
spoke to him afterwards and i was like
how did that look
you said it looks fine and i went well
because i was having a nightmare that
day he said that's fine it's fine it
looks great looks fantastic don't worry
about it and then later on we were out
for dinner
and i said to men that day i was that's
my least favorite day ever on set and i
think i was having an outer body
experience you know anxiety kind of
moment and he turned to me and he said
well if that's the first time it's ever
happened to you then you were owed one
because he said most of the time that
i'm working with actors it'll happen at
least once a production for one person
so everyone's having it in at least
one time for each actor in every one of
his productions so he said the fact that
it's happened just once in your career i
was like oh okay i mean i remember
getting to a point on lost
there were obviously days where i was
like oh this is a bit challenging but i
remember getting to a point on loss
where
they'd be like you know we would shoot
10 11 sometimes 12 pages a day and they
same with you they'd come to us at lunch
they'd be like we're doing really well
today so we're going to pull this scene
and it'll be a three-page scene and
you'd be like yeah okay i got it and you
think i could do that over lunch no
problem and the the honing of the muscle
would get so tight
because you you expected to perform on
that level and then you know you can
relax and drop into it so i i did feel
that did you feel that on smallville
yeah i think eventually it was a lot
easier how many seasons are smaller i
did seven
but uh you know
i always took it so seriously though and
i wanted to know my lines inside out and
have a day or two with them too so where
i could just talk to you like i am now
just grab this drink while i'm speaking
mm-hmm
i continue my dialogue without even
flinching not not practicing in front of
a mirror not just be raw and real and
just loose
so whenever somebody gives you something
when you don't have a lot of time it
means that you're not going to have the
freedom to really know it inside out to
really just it's it's part of you yeah
you know and and that is something that
i
need as an actor i i'm not i'm not i
mean i'll get it done i'll somehow
figure it out but i'm not afraid i've
never done it
but if i really thought you're just
gonna kill yourself i'd say get cute
cards out i don't give a [ __ ] get a cue
card out put it right there on camera
and i'll make it real i'll make it sound
real yeah i'm not gonna torture you guys
with this right i'm not gonna torture
myself with it this is what we're doing
yeah there are pranks that work right
yeah or you know there's there's
it happened to you
i i tried i i love you son of a [ __ ]
he's very professional he's very very
pretty i like to know my lines really
well yeah yeah
same as you i like to kind of feel as if
you know if something happens you you've
got the freedom to kind of let that
happen you know there was one time
actually i was doing a guest star on a
tv show
and i was supposed to do the big scenes
later on so i did know them but not as
well as i wanted to and they started
with like the biggest
you know like four pages of just
monologue basically
and they wanted they wanted me to be
packing a bag at the same time
so and and i love
uh i was saying this before it's on i
love the uh
technicals of a movie or tv i love to
get the continuity right
i love the idea of the editor going oh
he's giving me a really good editing
point there i love all that stuff
so to then
be packing a bag while i'm doing a
monologue that i didn't really know i
remember that annoyed me that day
because i was like i can't remember when
i picked that up i can't remember when i
put that down
you know by the time they went to the
second take the third take and i was
like oh i was starting to get me
you know what i know
yeah yeah so i have yeah
you also
i think
this is a
a slightly educated guess but you also
subscribe to the app oh footsie you also
subscribe to the idea of don't let
people see you sweat right you're kind
of that person yeah you don't want to i
don't i don't i don't want people to see
me sweat either some actors come on set
with the pages and they do a little okay
wait i'm doing this i think you kind of
like i've got this yeah probably yeah
that's how i am i am i i don't even
bring sides like you want to run lines
all right great let's do it boom boom
boom boom i like to do that i rarely
have sides i'll sometimes have sides but
maybe they'll be rolled up so i can't
look at them maybe maybe that but um i i
like to
just kind of be like free i i know this
stuff let's do it let's rock it i'm not
thinking about it i'm not thinking about
a tool rolling right but when i'm
thinking about it and i'm thinking about
it and i need to and i don't have it and
i don't have it they're throwing hey
let's add this i don't like that stuff i
don't like to go hey we're going to
change this line we're going to this i
go yeah but i say that then they say
something else which then i have to
it's it's a whole new reprogramming
it's just it's just not something my
brain is capable i think some people are
great at it it's so funny our actors are
all different right yeah yeah my
favorite thing with the director is
if we do take one and they like it and
then we cover ourselves we take two i
love it when a director comes over to me
and says we've got it
just going to slightly change it now
just just slightly tweak it lines are
going to kind of stay the same but maybe
we want you to do this and that so in
take three
the freshness now is that i'm thinking
there's a slightly new piece of business
or there's a slightly new way of exiting
or entering and that just it just spices
everything up so that's my favorite is
the director's team we've got it here's
a new thing to think about that's my
all-time favorite thing yeah i don't
mind that i love that note i like a
little i like a little bit of that yeah
yeah for sure um i was gonna say
something and it's falling out my brain
it's interesting hearing your guys
perspectives on that yeah it's
interesting yeah i like the fact that
all actors
or all actors processes i'm totally fine
with unless like i said i have a real
bee in my body
of people saying
well that's my process and their process
is at the expense of everyone else's
process and they can be a [ __ ] you
know you're like well what if the
cameraman's process is to be a [ __ ]
yeah would you be all right with that
you missed your [ __ ] mark right right
yeah you're another inch over
what are you doing christian bale
get over there yeah yeah no true little
bits like also you were saying that
thing about when you start to get the
props and stuff at the right time
bills and i have noticed a few times
sometimes we'll be recording something
at home
the two of us and once we get into the
flow our timing is exactly the same
right yeah billy's son will he'll cut at
the end and we'll go
how long does that jacket go a minute 17
we're like okay cool we'll do it again
how long they at minute 17 we're like oh
my god like it's it's
like women with their periods that's how
you guys are yeah we tune in yeah right
it's beautiful yeah beautiful thing
that was good one at dom isn't he lovely
though isn't it isn't he just i i really
like spending time with him hey before
we go yeah should we do a little
league of legends updates
because there has been some um there's
been movement movement as you might see
if you were constipated yes there's a
little bit of movement has there been
any movement oh it's put a road right
through me good news right so
we have been tracking
the progress of
elijah jordan wood
and sean astin playing league of legends
will they be joining our team which will
go pro we will go pro yeah we'll be
called uh
well just called the hobbits i guess
yeah
last week and for a couple of weeks
running elijah has been for me a lemon
seed yeah you've not been pleased which
just to recap a strawberry seed is the
lowest and a watermelon is the highest
and he's been a plum for me he's been a
plumber he's been a plum now a couple of
days ago was it yesterday yesterday i
think he sent us a little video to tell
us that he was playing league of legends
or so he thought oh was it a video was
that a still oh is it still yeah
i was disappointed if it was a video
that i never press play he did send us a
video after that oh carry on he sent us
a still of him playing
league of legends and you said oh you're
playing league of legends and i looked
at it and i thought that's not
summoner's rift he had accidentally
started playing tft which is a kind of
board game version of league of legends
and i said no no elijah that's not
summoner's rift league of legends and he
wrote back and said oh thank god this is
really boring i said yes it's like
basically like chess with the characters
from league of legends moving around
it's rubbish so i said come out of that
go into the actual game i sent him a
little video as to how to do it play the
tutorial he played the tutorial as lux
and as ari oh
wouldn't that be lovely to play a game
so what
as far as fruit goes dom where would you
say elijah wood there's no well if he's
played the two legends update i'm gonna
promote him from a lemon seed
to a
small
pear a bartlett pear all lovely
he's done well he's not played the game
yet uh-huh he's not played with us yet
so he's not quite there yet
i'll put him there well
i mean i think once he's he started what
she has done
a jaffa orange nice okay he's been
promoted
sean astin um he did send a thing at the
same time saying can you play it on
xbox otherwise i will invest in a
playstation and i wrote about
pc or mac and then he didn't really
respond so i think sean astin for me
nectarine pit
i mean he must have a pc or a computer
it's always working
things i'm going to say that he is a
tangerine
well we will keep you guys posted and on
the
fantastic day that all four of us play
league of legends together we might
bring in a watermelon to celebrate i
love it but we'll keep you updated with
league of legends anyway but this is the
league of legends in terms of can we get
all four hobbits playing brilliant
so that's it guys we will see you next
week make sure you um rate review and
subscribe to the podcast and don't
forget to send your emails and we love
the riddles so that's a good thing just
now i'm enjoying the riddles yeah they
are fantastic so send emails riddles
ideas plans
things that you want us to eat in billy
and dom
eat the world send it to knee advice
send it to
the friendship onion at cassmedia.com
or you can leave us a voicemail at
speakpipe.com
forward slash the friendship onion and
we will see you all next week see you
then
[Music]